your friend that you're working with in
logistics he's from ukraine had a chance
so what what do you think's going to
happen to ukraine when you're seeing you
know biden saying hey if you don't
attack
you know ukraine i will attend the
summit but if you do i will not you know
the ukraine prime minister saying stop
calling this and you're scaring the hell
out of my people just leave it alone we
got this putin's not going to do
anything we're in communication
where are you at with that
consumer prices went up 7.5 in january
inflation is out of control people go to
the store every day and they buy stuff
they see
higher prices
put gas in the car they see it
they look to their leaders
and they understandably blame them
biden's facing this now his approval
writings are really low his politics is
very bad
and
nothing like a good war okay to help you
in your domestic politics now do i think
biden is going to lead us into war over
ukraine i do not we will not go to war
with russia over ukraine do i think that
there's a real risk that russia might
invade the eastern part of ukraine yes
they did it in crimea it's very possible
do i think biden is exaggerating the
threat and his administration is
exaggerating that so much so that when
he calls zielinski the ukrainian
president and zalinski tells them stop
scaring our people it's not as bad as
you're saying it is do i think that's
cynical politics by biden i do
um
if you're asking me to predict an
outcome i i don't know that i have one
but i think uh it's a combination of
putin wants to
flex his muscles and
and he's fearful of nato expanding
further with ukraine and i think there
are a lot of ethnic issues in that part
of ukraine
where historically if you know anything
about that part
stalin had populated a lot of russian
nationals to that part of the ukraine
during the
famine in the late 1930s with his failed
collectivization socialist policies that
were starving the ukrainian people
because
they weren't producing enough
crops so
there's a real concept nothing's gonna
happen you think he's just trying to uh
he's bluffing you think putin's just
bluffing
i i don't i
it's hard for me to predict an outcome i
don't know what the outcome is going to
be do i think it's possible he might do
it he did it in crimea he he could do it
do i think he's if i bet on it would i
say he's going to do it when he's facing
the economic sanctions that he'd be
facing
from
the united states and western europe
i would think he's not going to do it
and then i think part of what he's doing
too is he's causing up to china his
relationship with china to build a
stronger relationship with china because
i think russia putin and russia feel
they've been isolated in the power game
so i think it's a i'm hoping that it's
more posturing and positioning than an
actual invasion but if you're asking me
to bet on it
i don't know i don't know what the
outcome is tulsi gabbard said she warns
the military industrial complex
wants a war in ukraine this is a
political insider story former
congressman tulsa gabriel echoed former
president eisenhower's famous warning on
saturday saying the neocons war mongers
have spent years
stoking the new cold war with russia and
have now brought us to the brink of
ukraine this serves their own interests
and lines uh the pocket of the
military-industrial complex with
trillions of dollars let's not be sheep
and then she told tucker later on what
we have unfortunately is democrats
republicans mainstream media the
washington elite essentially in the
pockets of the military-industrial
complex do you agree with that i think
there's a lot of truth to what she's
saying you know again
it's easy to be anti-russian in the
united states we were raised to fear the
soviet union and for many rightful
reasons my father fled communism when he
after world war ii and didn't go back to
his native yugoslavia because he wanted
to come to a country that he perceived
as being free and mostly was but
um
after the fall of the berlin wall and
after the dissolution of the former
soviet union promises were made to the
new russian country and their government
to yeltsin
by nato about expansion nato expansion
and while poland
i think rightfully should be in nato and
some of the other countries and maybe
ukraine at some point that remains to be
seen
but that a lot of these promises have
been broken
and when the united states and nato
decided to break up a sovereign country
yugoslavia where my father came from
over kosovo when they decided that they
were going to force
a sovereign country to give up a portion
of its country
because of the ethnic situations there
they created a
precedent and they basically
told the russians you're of no
consequence because historically the
russians have always been allies of the
serbs and that part of the region with
the complicated politics of the old
ottoman empire your people have been
screwed
the armenian genocide and all the rest
and so when nato and the united states
decided to break up a sovereign country
the way they did
that was a message to putin and the
russians you can't trust these people we
can't work with them and so a lot of
what you're seeing is a manifestation of
those relationships that go back 25
years
so if you're asking me to predict an
outcome
i don't really know what she is saying
do i believe that absolutely i sat on
the house armed services committee and i
voted i plead guilty to this i voted for
that war in iraq i remember sitting
there as a young congressman listening
watching all these joint chiefs of staff
generals under oath testify classified
hearings about the weapons of mass
destruction that were there and i'm
asking myself i remember could they be
lying because if they were there that
seems like we should get in there and go
get those weapons of mass destruction
and get them away from saddam hussein so
if it's true i have to vote for this war
hillary voted for the war and i remember
looking at hillary i'm thinking in
myself could they be lying i don't have
enough experience here so i want to look
to see what other senior members in the
congress are doing who would know better
and what better person than her she was
the former first lady and she was very
close to her husband when it came to the
governing side yeah she would know
whether or not these generals are lying
or not
well they lied right she voted for the
war i voted for the war bernie sanders
didn't i remember thinking man that
guy's something else he was right we
were wrong but we were lied to so when
kelsey gabbard says what she says about
the political industrial complex and
those neoconservatives who like to get
us involved in foreign
ventures and
halliburton those contractors and all
the rest do i believe it i absolutely do
do you think those generals actually
lied or the information that they
received from the people higher up
you know the military military
industrial complex was feeding them
misinformation because it's not like
these generals got rich off of this
right
no your point's well taken it's a lot
more complicated than whether or not
there's a blatant lie to you somebody
was lying along the way they may have
gotten a lot of misinformation faulty
intelligence
maybe just fake intelligence not sure
all i know is there were no weapons of
mass destruction there and we voted for
that war predicated on that so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you